as we mentioned southern california
arizona and nevada are getting blasted
by another potentially deadly heat wave
our lead national correspondent david
bagno is in palm springs california
where the desert heat
is an extreme threat david did i read
it's already in the 90s this morning
well look it was 100 degrees at midnight
midnight
100 degrees and this is more than just a
miserable inconvenience it's deadly
in fact we came to palm springs to
interview rescuers because they've seen
an
uptick in distress calls coming from
people who shouldn't be outside hiking
but are and sure enough just as soon as
we rolled into town
they got a 911 call it was just after 1
p.m local time the temperature outside
was 108 degrees
are you injured the call came into 9-1-1
with a man saying please help me
i am trapped on the side of a cliff i'm
not injured
i haven't i've been in the sun
what we're going to do we're getting to
find out the exact gps coordinates of
the patient
ping him from his cell phone get up to
the patient if we can
a crew of 20 some of them volunteer
search and rescuers
the decision was made to rescue the man
using a helicopter they said they're
going to hoist him the rescuers told us
the man should not have been out there
hiking in the first place is any hiking
recommended in these temperatures
no hiking when it's above 100 degrees
the rescue operation a success that
trapped hiker known only as james
was flown to safety so is this guy lucky
he's very lucky he still had a cell
phone signal
he still had a cell phone signal but
look at the way he was dressed
pair shorts the sun's going to cook you
out here what happened that you needed
to call 9-1-1
i was on the edge of a cliff he went
down somewhere and i went down somewhere
else i took rocks out of my shoes and
lost track of them and that was it he
was lucky
jeffrey martin seer was not this is the
last photo of jeffrey
lounging by the pool during the last
heat wave in mid-june
and that's all he was doing for more
than an hour officials say he was not
hiking
not doing anything strenuous but it was
119 degrees that day
tying a record jeffrey was planning on
meeting his friend jill langham for a
drink
at a bar called hunters he sent her this
ominous text message
he's so winded will explain when i see
you
inching my way towards hunters jeffrey
never made it
he collapsed and later died of
complications
related to heat stroke jeffrey's body
temperature was reportedly 105 degrees
you know during that last heat wave we
had toward the end of june in british
columbia canada
the heat reportedly cooked little sea
creatures in their shells we're talking
about mussels mussels clams snails cook
those little suckers
in their shells all because of the heat
think about that the beauty of the sun
is also the power of the sun david thank
you very much